this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at even more of the weapons found
in the multiplayer of 2022's Call Of
Duty Modern Warfare 2. so that round you
can see at the back as he theatrically
spins this in the air seems like a
really silly idea if you drop it you're
in trouble because this thing will
probably unspool and vomit cartridges
all over the floor make sure to
subscribe as we've got two previous
episodes to take a look at more of
Modern Warfare 2's multiplayer guns and
if you'd like to help out the Royal
armories Museum and continue to support
Jonathan's work check the links in the
description of this video right let's
take a look at more of the weapons of
Modern Warfare 2.
foreign
what is now the xm250 and looks very
likely that it's very high pressure high
performance 6.8 millimeter round to
replace the well certainly the M249 and
hence the name and rolled it up by one
but also very likely the m240 as well
this thing no reason why this thing
can't do both now that half has happened
between modern warfares one and two and
this looks to be the same it's probably
had a graphics up upgrade but it seems
to be the same design as the one from
Modern Warfare 2019 which means that
they have carried over prototype design
features that have since been abandoned
and have a look at the images you can
see the Contours of the receivers are
different the hand guards different butt
stock is different as well as some of
the changes they had made to the
original prototype design that make it
more
a Cod gun slightly different in detail
notably the lower forward part of the
gun the low receiver at the front is
shaped very differently to either the
Prototype or the current gun so it's
become quite far removed from what is
actually has actually seen adoption
this is clearly very cut down we have
got examples of solar shotguns I don't
have onto ham it's very satisfying that
the reload is sound and looks really
cool maybe a little bit aggressive in
the in the braking of itself normally
you have to manually break a shotgun you
don't usually get to just flick a catch
and it breaks itself like that I do
appreciate that slick reload there that
looks plausible it looks like a column
of two cartridges from a sort of speed
belt like they're using a competition
shotgun shooting so you're grasping both
rounds in one hand and then dropping one
one in
using pressure one above and then the
second one in closing it out if you had
to speed reload the sword off over and
under shotgun then that seems like how
you might do it
[Applause]
something called an HCR 56 so I have a
gunsmith view in front of me orbit the
biggest thing we've got is this
Australia Aug this is a vintage piece as
some of our stuff is because we're a
museum but it's roughly the same
configuration obviously because with a
with a support weapon you want a little
bit more effective rate of fire by means
of a larger magazine but you are limited
to that that box magazine which is why
the game version has that sort of uh I
think magpul-esque drum magazine that
comes with it so it lets you use it for
longer in the game albeit it in a Call
of Duty game you're not really using it
for its intended purpose of giving
support fire I suppose you can try I
don't think many players online are
going to be doing that maybe I'm just
old and cynical the main the lower
receiver is essentially this first
generation diet design with the usual
modern Call of Duty tweaks the elephant
in the room is the foregrip because I'm
not aware of an Aug lower receiver that
replaces the folding vertical foregrip
that's attached to it's actually
attached to the barrel not even the
upper
places that with something fitted to
the lower suffice to say this this is a
fictional fictionalized version of the
gun and there are a couple of Minor
Details as well that aren't very much
right next one pp19 he's on but this is
the original uh well not the very early
type before they did away with this
nonsense
because this helical magazine design has
never seemingly worked out now what's
interesting here is how identical the
design of the magazine appears to be the
model of the one in game given what we
keep speculating on with regards to
different designs in the game so for
those of you who aren't aware this is if
it's not obvious from how it works in
the game this is a spiral as in helical
pencilable it's feed and your your
bullet emerges or a cartridge sorry it
emerges here this is a this is a
follower so that round you can see at
the back as he theatrically spins this
in the air which seems like a really
silly idea because if you drop it you're
in trouble because this thing will
probably unspool and vomit cartridges
all over the floor but I digress
Arrangement is as depicted hooks at the
front which are steel inserts into the
polymer to hook it onto the gun like so
now I think the way that is depicted on
here is the same this at the end is your
wind-up mechanism
hopefully you can see I'll turn it part
way and let it go just so you get the
idea
Clockwork magazine it has to be in order
to function so that applies rearward
pressure to the column of cartridges
which spiral down to the bottom and are
forced out of the hole here C1 on screen
held by the feed lifts of the magazine
right I will try to set aside my my
absolute burning hatred of the modified
front sights on all of the hacker and
[ __ ] weapons in this game except I
failed to clearly I focus on the
positives which is that well we've got
this which is very cool this is an hk33
that means it's in 5.56 millimeters
which is what this is although it does
the model as as seen in the initial
screen there lacks the magazine release
assume I can't quite see that the player
is therefore using the push button
magazine release Here
which is very awkward and I don't know
of anyone that uses them on any HK
weapons because I've got quite long
fingers and I can barely reach it now
this isn't clearly identical to the one
in the game but pretty similar including
this rather interesting olive drab uh
color for the grip frame for the low
receiver effectively and indeed the butt
stock so if this was a solid stock
version it would look quite similar to
what we've seen here but the solid stock
there's no HK solid stuff that I know of
That's So contoured and sculpted that's
a fictional bit of furniture clearly the
other reason I grabbed this is it does
in fact have a grenade launcher not too
dissimilar from what's depictive there
but overall it's a it's a very sort of
cool looking maybe a bit more
Black Ops Cold War than the Modern
Warfare but then so is the version
that's in front of me I think
this thing looks like closest thing that
looks like is the sa-25 which is a I
believe third generation man pads Man
portable air defense system guided
missile basically we don't have one of
those we don't specialize at all in
guided missile systems here but we do
have one uh this is the sa7 so this is
the granddaddy to esa25 it has a lot of
the same features there's a thermal
battery up front here a fiberglass tube
illuminated fold down sights on it and
sighting system on it's probably the one
of the major leagues forward with later
air defense missile systems it has the
uh what's called the grip stock firing
module Electronics in the back here and
the grip and Trigger up front part of
the grip stock on this version anyway is
a bit of a comedy speaker in the side
because you do need that launch uh or
lock-on tone I don't think it wouldn't
sound like that that necessarily on this
or even on the modern version but you do
need to be able to hear that tone near
your head nice and clearly to be able to
know when it's Seeker on the missile not
on the launcher is locked on Modern
systems are more sort of all aspect and
they can pick up on Lower amounts of
heat whether they'd be good enough to be
able to lock onto a vehicle on the
ground and fire and successfully engage
that I genuinely don't know as far as I
know you also can't bypass the lock on
the guidance system and fire these
things without a lock on as we see in
the gameplay footage pretty sure you
can't do that there wouldn't be a lot of
point in firing a missile blind into the
air is completely pointless
foreign
gun although I imagine it unlocks as
part of the x13 is it they're the Glock
18. assuming pistols workers platforms
which I haven't seen but
um then it would be as in reality a sort
of upgrade for a pistol fully automatic
pistol in this case what does it give
you well about stock making more precise
with it or it's and or to control fully
automatic fire better that's the real
advantage of a chassis kit like this
like the Roni or the Fab defense I think
this looks a bit more like that latter
than that but it's probably an
original-ish design you can see the
pistol bit sticking out the bottom and
it's coupled there with a drum magazine
and those two yeah those three things
make for quite a bit of Firepower in a
compact sort of package but it's a sort
of why would you bother if you are a
special operations person you would buy
a small submachine gun or a machine
pistol so then they're not without value
certainly but um there are better ways
to achieve automatic pistol caliber fire
than a conversion kit that's really
geared more towards civilians for
semi-automatic use I think it's fair to
say
all right a quite specific model of rpk
which is one of the only guns in the
game to have its actual name interesting
now the um the graphics on this this
game are obviously superb uh I haven't
really commented too much on how well
things are modeled or textured focused
more on how different they are from
their real life counterparts suffice to
suffice it to say the graphics are
superb lighting texturing the lot and
this this rpk is no exception something
we've had comments on before is the
Fidelity of wood in game engines and
Graphics engine and to be fair they it
has been sort of glossed over slap a
shiny texture on there to imply varnish
the resolution isn't necessarily superb
wood has so much texture to it that a a
flat wrapped around texture does not do
it justice you almost ideally would need
to model in 3D the Grain and then
texture that I don't think we're doing
that yeah correct me if I'm wrong um
game developers but I I gotta go out on
a limb and say that the wooden furniture
on this rpk is probably the best I've
seen
it has a variety of texture of wear of
color of Sheen it looks about as good as
I would I would expect wood to look
[Music]
so in our single player review We I
commented on the FN SCAR alike which is
in the game as well this is a part of
the same platform and it shares all of
the same differences and somewhat
similarity of the not scar that we saw
last time this though is a different
model effectively this is a precision
rifle or DMR and it's the somewhat close
to the FN well FN SCAR Mark 20 so that's
the US military designation for a
designated Marksman version of the of
the scar which is the mark 17. they all
I think I'm right saying have that
monolithic upper receiver that extends
past the gas block where the site
fold-up site would be and has a window
in either side for you to reach in and
adjust your gas setting and if the gun
is not running properly because dirt or
whatever you change the gas setting so
you need those big rectangular windows
in the body of the gun effect to access
that here we have a hand guard that sort
of stops short of the gas block like the
mark 17 would but then it has an
extension that runs out past the gas
block and a lower height curiously and
the whole point of Monolithic uppers is
well or even pseudo monolithic ones with
separate handguards is that they present
a flat top all the way down the barrel
as far as you need it for your
accessories and stuff and this doesn't
do that so it gives it quite a different
profile
thank you this thing has quite an
interesting Optical sight set up here
obviously that's customizable but um it
is interesting to look at we're used to
the the hybrid arrangement for sites
here in Call of Duty some years ago it's
a real thing you either press a button
and flip the thing out of the way or you
just it's on a sort of biased cantilever
Mount and it swings it out of the way
this is somehow actuating it to go up
into your sight line and down into a
stowed position below your site I
haven't seen that done in the real world
um anyone has let me know it seems
mechanically difficult to achieve I mean
you wouldn't have to worry too much
about zero Precision of it moving around
too much and losing your brain
potentially because it's just um in
theory it's just a magnifier this also
has a thermal function as well now as I
only recently learned a pane of glass
will prevent a thermal imager from
seeing through it it's like it's like a
wall so if the optic is has a glass
plate glass
screen that would be a problem maybe
this one is polymer or something I don't
know if that would have the same effect
I'm not very good on thermal properties
of things it did stick out to me as an
interesting setup there and I'm not sure
how realistic it is
[Music]
thank you for watching everyone that was
of course more guns from Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2. as ever you can help
us out greatly here at the Royal
armories by really just by checking out
our own YouTube channel and of course by
visiting us if you're at all able to do
so obviously if you're thousands of
miles away that's a bit of a problem but
if you're here on vacation or something
we have three museums around the country
that you can hopefully make it to one of
them thanks again guys we'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]